c'est une nouvelle que personne
n'attendait alors que depuis plusieurs
semaines la société de production
endemol shine avait décidé de mettre à
disposition du public plusieurs épisodes
de la première saison de la star academy
voilà qu'aujourd'hui elle annonce le
potentiel retour de cette émission culte
des années 2000 à la télévision c'est la
non surprise faite par vincent panneaux
le directeur des programmes du groupe de
production nous travaillons sur
différents programmes autour d'une star
ac' nouvelle génération l'année
prochaine c'est l'anniversaire des 20
ans ça se fête pour lui la star academy
a toute sa place à la télévision
aujourd'hui je suis persuadé qu'un jour
l'émission reviendra car elle fonctionne
par cycles il y aurait toujours ce côté
apprentissage et aussi de grands prime
avec des live si on ne sait pas encore
quelle forme prendra ce retour nikos
aliagas qui à l'époque avait fait ses
armes à la star academy pourrait lui
aussi participé à ce come-back
sentimentalement oui ça me ferait
plaisir ce serait super une émission
spéciale entre potes dans un esprit
nostalgique ça m'amuserait beaucoup de
revoir les anciens candidats et toute
l'équipe
une réponse qui laisse penser que
d'anciens élèves pourrait participer à
l' aventure alors assisterons nous à une
saison all star à l'heure actuelle les
producteurs restent prudents en 2012
c'est nrj12 qui avait tenté de relancer
le programme sur son antenne une
émission qui avait rassemblé en moyenne
1,2 million de fidèles durant les prime
à leur retour de la star ac
j'y crois ou j'y crois pas le retour de
la star ac' j'y crois ou j'y crois pas
je vous le dis depuis le 21 avril
nd et molsheim diffuse chaque jour un
nouvel épisode de la star ac sur youtube
de la saison une et ça marche très bien
donc c'est ça qui leur a donné l'idée
sachez le alors les confidences de nikos
nikos eux je pense qui d'après ce que je
sais ils aimeraient bien animé juste un
prime mais pas refaire toute une saison
de la star academy c'est ce que j'ai
compris a priori après je sais pas si
c'est voilà nikos va chauffer de façon
est ce que vous y croyez ou retour de la
star academy vous je vous pose la
question valérie bénaïm oui moi j'y
crois parce que je crois beaucoup aux
émissions qui sortent sur la nostalgie
on a une nostalgie de cette émission
c'était une émission phare une émission
culte l'année 2000 et ont peu sale avait
une belle image
maj vraiment très sympa de gamins qui
avaient envie de réussir un truc
infaillible française je pense que c'est
ça fonctionnera toujours un film à la
con c'est surtout quelle gauche de
l'autre côté en train de décliner donc
il faut trouver un nouveau télé crochet
qui en fait état un niveau c'est quand
même des codes auxquels et les
spectateurs de tête habitués donc ça
pourrait être une jolie alternative mais
encore faut-il que l'accent soit
vraiment le gros barnum avec les homos
alors est ce qu'il y avait dans la star
academy et c'est ça qu'il faudrait c'est
que c'était l'émission qui recevait le
plus de stars françaises et
internationales y avait johnny céline
dion britney spears katy perry madonna
kylie minogue et charles aznavour qui
est venu regarder vous a fait une petite
compil de toutes les stars donc il pas
s'essayer à la star academy
quand j'ai revu ça je me suis dit ah
ouais quand même c'était quand même bien
lourd garde et encore
[Musique]
car et c'est le temps
jouer de la vie comme on joue deux
le chien chez noma
on y voit dans les flammes
jeudi j'ai très décent
aucunement
il
[Musique]
je
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez dit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors la star academy retour de la star
academy est ce que vous dites que vous y
croyez vous y croyez pas après moi je
vous donnais mon sentiment et j'ai
quelques petites infos voudrais me
sentais non si ça va revenir ou pas jean
michel maire qui croit ou pas mais oui
si je trouve même la question badge
débile évidemment que je n'y crois pas
c'est un naufrage annoncé
mais franchement vous êtes des enfants
ou une raison essentielle pourquoi la
fin la nostalgie sont sous la télé ne
tombe en panne ils sont par nostalgie
pourquoi ça c'est illégal parce que
c'est moderne non je regarde si ces mots
d avoir de stade ou attentatoires quand
je vais te dire un truc je veux juste te
dire un truc tu nous disais hier que tu
adores et le jeu à prendre ou à laisser
je vais faire vont penser moi quand
c'est moi la nostalgie c'est bien on va
faire les autres en cfa c'est de la
merde tu te fout de la gueule on est
d'accord
l'adjani la mécanique des boîtes et des
percussions de ses indémodables ans je
te le dire écoute moi si tu me convient
une minute en minute ont été détruits
programme
vas-y vas-y c'était quoi les trois
mamelles des trois mamelles de la star
ac et l'encerclement l'enfermement
il n'y a plus qu'une seule émission de
territet d'enfermement dans le monde
entier on sent ce qui m'attend ou de
voir des paysages émargeant d'erlon là
on est plus enfermer on est confiné donc
d'accord d'accord
l'enfermement ça ne marche plus la
deuxième demie mais c'est le direct le
diesel g d'émission qui faisait leur
tour de sport leurs cours de chant les
rayons dans sa salle 6 hectares seraient
qu'à un stade rennais modestie sa
démission
et qu'est ce qui marche maintenant des
marseillais parce que la troisième
mamelles c'était la découverte de
talents on s'en fout des talons matin
elle est témoin à pourrir les choses en
m'écoutant dont tout le monde y compris
les dénicheurs grégory lemarchal
elodie frégé ma tante a découvert grâce
à the boys nouvelle star tu secoues à
pamiers il ya du talent vous tombez donc
étant salut ça marche plus ce qui marche
c'est les marseille bande de potes et
leurs rencontres amoureuses et à défaut
de montage pas de direct du montage pour
monter les rebondissements le suspense
les alliances des alliances et cetera
voilà qui marche mais ça ne marche plus
le gouvernent talent en direct
ioumachev run & bike à torreilles il ya
le foot
les professions scientifiques les
émissions télé réalité il ya souvent un
partenaire ce que nous on n'en clientèle
rené on te parle dans deux minutes
on va revoir je voulais montrer à la
fois le premier lancement de nikos
regarde elle était tout jeune de la star
ac c'est sa première émission sur tf1 il
avait été débauché de france 2 on revoit
juste ça et vous nous dites vous raymond
tu me dis si tu y crois toi la star ac
ou pas c'est parti bonsoir
soyez le bienvenu en direct sur tf1 nous
sommes le samedi 8 octobre
il est exactement 20 ans 53 vous avez
entendu parler ces derniers temps de
star académie aujourd'hui c'est le grand
soir
bienvenue soyez les bienvenus à star
académie que va-t-il se passer
la star academy ne récompense que les
meilleurs je vous rappelle qu'ils
étaient cent mille au départ je sais que
vous êtes impatients de découvrir les
visages de 50 ans et finaliste 50
finalistes que vous avez sélectionné
chaque soir sur tf1 a lancé le moment
mesdames messieurs je vous demande de
leur faire un triomphe il de mérite
parce qu'ils sont mort de trac
voici les cinq ans finaliste de la star
academy
[Applaudissements]
or alors je vais vous montrer une vidéo
de nikos dans un instant puisqu'une
vidéo qui était passée inaperçue et je
pense qu'on va faire une petite rigolade
raymond est ce que tu crois
et ça ait réagi énormément sur les
réseaux sociaux et bien sûr en direct
sur le retour de la star academy hier
vous allez voir on y croit on y croit
pas vas-y mon raymond non mais moi j'y
crois mais j'ai peur au fond de moi j'ai
peur d'y croire d'une certaine nostalgie
j'ai envie de revoir ça jean lui comme
l'a dit valérie est un mélange de ce
vice et de télé réalité 2 en 1 mais
attention que ce soit pas ma nostalgie à
moi perso qui me donne envie d'y croire
parce que l'argument ça marche sur
youtube ça ça me fait très peur parce
que youtube ça dépend qui consomme lieu
de rencontre pour son mieux tube on
regarde pas forcément l'appeller des
fois tu vas sur you tube tu vois un
titre de jean jacques goldman
au grand jeu règles magasins moores café
200000 vue et rené me suis bien fait
comment ils me l'ont dit donc on fait
faire attention youtube mais la star et
j'y crois je vais regarder moi j'ai
regardé pour voir ce que ça donne
justement on voudrait avoir une petite
vidéo de nikos qui est passée inaperçue
on l'a très peu vu mais qui est très
drôle à l'époque nico faisait un petit
peu le foufou il était tout foufou nikos
sur le plateau et en silence et la
publicité
il faisait des pirouettes et ils
couraient sur le plateau sauf carrément
à faire le fou fou et bat regarder juste
avant les fêtes de noël et juste après
le pourcentage de plus
bientôt c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais c'est ça le direct comme disait
raymond et ouais c'est ça le direct et
c'est vrai que nous a fait ce qu'on
appelle une shy'm maintenant dans le
métier d'ailleurs on embrasse oui jean
michel oui oui non je comprends que j'ai
une certaine pudeur mais je suis assez
content que pour le magnéto le may et de
dix ans quand il ment comme au jour qui
manque dit que des bêtises comme une
fois de plus le format la star academy
avait été relancée sur nrj12 et s'était
présenté par matthieu delormeau et tonya
kinzinger j'aurais juste vous montrer
une petite vidéo dans la nouvelle
version de la star ac il ya une rigolade
qui a fait tous les bêtisiers c'est
quand tonya kinzinger en fait respecter
un peu trop le pont coeur et sur le
compteur on met des indications ça veut
dire par exemple regarde à droite lance
la pub et on met en même temps le texte
à dire bonjour à tous 1
attention on regarde cette caméra et lte
un moment non elle lit elle de retourner
vous mais ronnie wood était le genre
regardez à balancer des noms qui de
mathilde collinet tony quittera
définitivement le château
retournez vous voilà mais avant les
adieux accueillant à nouveau les débits
prg à la waho la revoir les appels se
rend compte là et en plus c'est les gens
qui regardent et regarder tout cela sans
vous serez de mathilde collinet tony
quittera définitivement le château
retournez vous voilà mais avant les
adieux accueillons à nouveau les débits
presse et d'une alfa voilà est génial